you
or at the Anaheim Heritage Center which
is inside the Museo facility we are the
local history collection for the Anaheim
Public Library and we were established
back in 1967 we're going to talk about
Anaheim in the 1920s one specific period
of time where Anaheim became known as
clan hime because of the Ku Klux Klan
and its presence in the county but
particularly in Anaheim and some of the
activities that occurred Anaheim in the
1920s were a small rural community
predominantly our economy is based on
agriculture with the village of orange
being our primary crop we are post-world
War One so there had been a very
nationalistic kind of patriotic you know
response to the end of the war and the
fact that we had won it and but there
are certain kinds of undercurrents shall
we say in the not just Anaheim but in
the communities in California as well as
other areas of the United States and
they include things like we do have
anti-immigration issues that have come
up basically people are saying that
there's they're stealing our jobs that
type of thing not very uncommon the
other thing that has also come to light
if you think about it
Anaheim was created as a winemaking
colony back in 1857 and although we are
no longer winemaking colony we still
have associated businesses we have an a
brewery and the anti brewery we also
have a few wineries that are still in
business but we definitely serve alcohol
we have hotels we have restaurants etc
this Anaheim is a wet town there's no
doubt about that we are the place to
come if you want to be served alcohol
but this is the time of working up to
the prohibition and one of the things
that the Klan picks up on is that there
is a point of contention between the
old-time Anaheim errs who aren't looking
forward to Prohibition
and the people that obviously are
prohibition supporters here in Anaheim
so they actually basically piggyback on
to the publisher of one of our two daily
newspapers the Orange County Plain
Dealer who is very supportive of
prohibition and it's basically accusing
the City Council at that time of kind of
dragging their feet and they're not
really supporting that etc and basically
forces the City Council into passing an
ordinance a year before prohibition goes
into effect Nash nationwide into
basically drying out Anaheim now it
seems to very quickly happen that
Anaheim becomes quickly known as the
stronghold for the Klan one of the ways
you can actually see that is this
wonderful panoramic view that we have in
our collection that was taken in
probably about at the high point of the
Klan activity here in Anaheim and Orange
County it's not taken in Anaheim it's
actually taken at Huntington Beach one
of the things that I noticed first was
the fact that they're not hiding their
faces they're all exposed you will see
that the front of the crowd are women
and that there are actually a number of
young children that are dressed in the
regalia as well it's a significant
number of people that you're seeing in
this this group so it does lend support
to the fact that it was a large group
probably not in the thousands as was
sometimes claimed by the Klan but
certainly more than a couple hundred
people I would think to counter the Klan
activity if you will in Anaheim Lotus
Loudoun who is the publisher of our
other daily paper the Anaheim Bulletin
is publishing obviously editorials
they're promoting their own candidates
for office they're trying to you know
again the other side of the coin we're
not we are following the letter of the
law we are supporting prohibition you
know for example here's one of their
newspapers and basically he's saying
their pastor expresses Klan smokescreen
dry issue to mislead voters so they're
basically using again the Anaheim
bulletin as their voice to counter what
the Klan is basically accusing the old
the old families of you know that
they're you know really not you know the
type of Anaheim that you want to be
basically one of the lists of members
one of which we have here in our
collection was purchased by Lotus loud
and for about two hundred dollars but
what's interesting is it does list
countywide who is on their membership
roles he does not publish it in total
but he does start including a lot of
these names in his articles and
editorials and among them are for
recently elected City Council members
and one of whom is actually the mayor
and so they used that as a basic basis
to actually generate enough local
support to start a recall election of
those four people on the City Council
the Klan through the Plain Dealer
actually turns around and tries to do a
recall election and actually succeeds
gets they get enough signatures to try
to recall the non Klan member so again
based on the list and they said well you
know this is your list we're not making
this up one of the things that is
published by the bulletin is basically
this advertisement which says we want
you to vote YES on the recall of these
four clans supported City Council people
and vote no on the recall of the one who
isn't who by the way has ties to
Anaheim's early families and then very
publicly people that are supporting this
have allowed them to publish their names
in the paper so that other people who
are reading this can see oh hey you know
doctor you know dr. truck saw is
supporting this he's my doctor I trust
him you know there must be something to
this so I think the fact that he was
allowed to actually published Lotus land
published the names of these supporters
of the recall really made a difference
because the recall election which was
held in spring of 1925 was successful
and they totally because at the same
time they had non Klan members up for
election and so that it was a sweep
Godfrey stock was allowed to keep his
seat and then the other four were
removed and four new people were
actually added to City Council I think
it's really important that you
acknowledge the bad incidents in your
history especially when you look at how
easy and how how adaptable the Klan was
to the existing issues that were
happening in town and used those to
become very strong you know in in our
city government so we don't want that to
happen again I mean the whole point of
history and examining history is to
learn from it
our cities tour staff recently traveled
to Anaheim California to learn about its
rich history learn more about Anaheim
and other stops on our tour at c-span
org slash cities tour